patrick que rue bonjour bonjour merci de
nous avoir rejoints dans la matinale de
rtl france alors le quartier des jardins
d'eole dans le nord de paris encore
tristement sous le feu des projecteurs
avec cette agression la semaine dernière
d'un enfant de deux ans par une
toxicomane qu'est ce qui s'est passé
précisément bien écouté dans un passage
à côté du métro stalingrad une mère de
famille avec son jeune enfant de deux
ans dans sa poussette a été pris à
partie par une toxicomane qui sur la
selon la police avaient de lourds
troubles psychiatriques et dans
l'échauffourée la toxicomane aurait
donné un coup de 5 à la maman et en
voulant l'éviter c'est le jeune enfant
de deux ans qui a pris le sac en plein
visage alors si l'agression de cet
enfant est une première les agressions
ll se succèdent finalement dans votre
quartier les agressions sont
quotidiennes donc c'est tous les jours
et depuis la mise en place de ce
dispositif fin le 17 mai donc dans le
parc et hall où des centaines de
toxicomanes viennent tous les jours
consommer à ciel ouvert est évidemment
quand ils sortent du parc
que ce soit la journée ou la nuit quand
ils sortent du dispositif
à une heure du matin et bien qu est ce
qu ils font qu'ils agressent les
riverains qui rentrent chez eux ou
sortent de chez eux pour aller au
travail
du coup les enfants et les mères de
famille mes parents ils ne peuvent plus
aller aujourd'hui donc dans ce fameux
parc qui est finalement occupé par les
fumeurs de crack et cela alors si parce
que le parc est très grand il fait deux
hectares et demi il est littéralement
coupé en deux vous avez la partie sud où
les familles continuent à aller et toute
la partie nord qui est quasiment
réquisitionnés par les consommateurs de
crack
alors vous vous mobilisez on le disait
maintenant depuis plusieurs semaines les
autorités 1 2
les autorités parisiennes elle ce
qu'elle vous entende ou pas oui tout à
fait madame hidalgo a écrit une lettre
au premier ministre jean castex en réel
et en relayant vraiment point par point
ce que nous lui demandions c'est-à-dire
l'évacuation du parc le plus rapidement
possible et surtout la prise en charge
10 mille s'établir à l'être structures
médico sociales pour l'ensemble de ces
toxicomanes c'est à dire qu'il faut
créer plusieurs des structures et
évidemment pas au coeur de quartiers
très dense comme celui de stalingrad
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas de
retour qu'un madame hidalgo
ça signifie qu'elle n'avait pas de
retour du premier ministre concernant
ces deux mondes
depuis combien de temps le quartier de
stalingrad finalement vit cette
situation qui est un enfer pour les
riverains ça fait plusieurs années que
les consommateurs de crack ce sont en
journée installé peu à peu dans le parc
dans la partie nord est depuis le
démantèlement en 2020 de la colline du
cra qui était porte de la chapelle
s'établir à 300 net et bien tous les
consommateurs de crack ont reflué vers
le parc est sonné le quartier stalingrad
voilà donc ça fait déjà plusieurs années
en réalité qu'on subit cette proximité
avec des centaines de toxicomanes mais
là depuis le 17 mai c'est vraiment ils
viennent de toute l'europe il faut quand
même le savoir il ya une présence
policière importante depuis
non non il ya eu un renforcement de
patrouille
mais on ne peut pas vraiment dire qu'il
ya un renforcement des patrouilles
policières
d'ailleurs la police ne vient plus dans
le parc c'est la direction c'est là les
groupements de sécurité de la ville de
paris qui viennent mais pas toute la
journée donc parfois le parc est livré à
lui-même en pleine journée notamment les
week-ends où il ya des centaines
d'enfants présents donc est derrière ce
drame humain deux de ces personnes
toxicomanes
il y a aussi tout un quartier qui est
dégradée
oui évidemment parce que les
conservateurs de crâne savez c'est une
rock et très destructrice
donc pour les plus on va dire ceux qui
sont le plus en déshérence et une non
plus vraiment leur conscience
il se met en danger eux-mêmes et les
rythmes et en plus ils dégradent
fortement
l'habitat des personnes lisant tri
fracturé les portes qu'ils entrent dans
les résidences
ils dorment n'importe où ils fracturent
nos caves c'est très difficile a dit
très clairement la nuit est ce qu'on
peut encore se déplacer seul à pied dans
ce quartier oui vous pouvez mais il faut
faire très attention
vraiment vous demandez à des agressions
ennemis de rivera vous demandez quoi
aujourd'hui très concrètement ce que
nous demandons c'est la fin de ce parc
âge brutale des toxicomanes dans le parc
ayroles c'est à dire que le parquet
hommes soient complètement rendue à ses
usagers qui n'y plus de toxicomanes qui
rentre dans le pas ça ça passe par un
gardiennage renforcé du matin au soir de
l'ouverture à la fermeture du tas quand
je vous dis un gardiennage renforcé ce
sont 10 20 30 gardiens
ce parc en a besoin plus que tous les
autres parcs parisiens
voilà ce que nous demandons en premier
la deuxième chose ce que nous demandons
à l'état au gouvernement français c'est
de prendre en charge dignement ces
personnes que sont les toxicomanes qui
souffrent au quotidien de leur addiction
il n'y a pas d'autres moyens c'est la
seule issue possible
est-ce que vous avez constaté des
personnes du quartier excédés qui qui
sont partis qui ont dû déménager
oui il ya beaucoup de déménagements dans
notre résidence
effectivement on a vu ça où en discutant
avec les riverains puisque nous sommes
un groupe d'organisateurs qui faisons du
tractage de rue à la rencontre des
risques pour leur expliquer pour
échanger avec eux parce que les gens
souffrent tellement qu'ils ont besoin de
parler d'exprimer leur souffrance donc
ils viennent nous voir
effectivement la première réaction c'est
on n'en peut plus mais
les riverains enfin comme partout
ailleurs ils sont attachés à leur
quartier
ça fait 10 20 30 ans parfois plus qui
vivifie donc effectivement ils sont
déchirés ils n'en peuvent plus de cette
situation ils voudraient partir mais en
même temps ils veulent pas partir parce
que ce quartier et même vous comprenez
c'est très difficile merci en tout cas
patrick cru pour votre témoignage ce
matin dans la matinale de rtl france